bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi
paris n'aura pas les jeux olympiques en
2012 c'est la ville de londres qui a été
choisi avec 54 voix contre 50
scènes de liesse en grande bretagne
c'est une nouvelle victoire pour tony
blair qui parle de jour historique et
qui promet je cite des jeux formidables
pour la france la désillusion est
terrible
al'annonce de la décision certains
champions n'ont pu retenir leurs larmes
elle débute polémique aussi des membres
du comité dénonce les méthodes
britannique avec nous à singapour le
maire de paris bertrand delanoë est la
championne d'escrimé laura flessel
jacques chirac et tony blair se
retrouvent ce soir en écosse pour
l'ouverture du g8
l'image de la poignée de mains ce
radiation observés à la loupe sur le
fond un accord semble en vue en ce qui
concerne l'aide à l'afrique incertitudes
en revanche sur le réchauffement
climatique
c'est officiel à monaco le prince albert
a reconnu publiquement être le père d'un
garçon de 22 mois né d'une liaison avec
une ancienne hôtesse de l'air
autre confirmation l'enfant ne pourra
pas prétendre au trône mais il aura sa
part d'héritage la vie et les vacances
ont repris leur cours à puget sur argens
dans le var après l'incendiaire l'
enquête a commencé les gendarmes
relèvent des indices
enfin le tour de france tom boonen battu
sur le fil au sprint c'est l'australien
robbie mcewen qui s'impose pas de
changement au classement général lance
armstrong toujours en jaune la france
espérait la france y croyait mais c'est
bien la grande bretagne qui l'a coiffé
sur le poteau et qui accueillera la
flamme et les jeux olympiques dans sept
ans en juillet 2012 comme prévu au terme
de cette journée à singapour londres et
paris sont arrivés en finale quatre voix
ont fait la différence sur place à
singapour manuel tissier vincent
bouffartigue
soudés comme des rugbymen en mêlée et
comme au rugby
les anglais gagnent souvent à la fin
d'un côté la france qui pleure de
l'autre londres en fait la fin du film
est un peu triste mais le combat
s'achève loyalement paris échoue pour la
troisième fois en 20 ans quatre voix
d'écart entre les finalistes
maigre consolation
finale ou pas final 1 5 ans et la
victoire leur est d'amasser pas à croire
qu ils ont choisi londres
ils ont certainement leur leur raison et
on ne peut que l'accepter
malheureusement sebastian cour peut
sortir en triomphateur paris avait la
faveur des pronostics dans cette finale
mais ces alliances étaient trop fragiles
dur à avaler c'est le sport il faut
respecter le vainqueur même ça fait mal
même si
et même si les mots ne viennent pas les
questions affluent le dossier était bon
le pays enthousiaste mais les jeux
seront en anglais en 2012 les anglais
comme sur un terrain de rugby on est
dans le sport quand même ne s'arrête
jamais jamais jamais ils ont fait un
lobbying de forcenés nous faisions le
même avec plus de discrétion peut-être
mais en moins
on se fait battre dans l'intérêt général
les londoniens estime plutôt qu'ils ont
gagné grâce à leur coeur et leur leader
je crois vraiment que le charisme de
sebastian coe qui est capable de
transmettre sa passion du sport y
compris aux plus jeunes a été encore
plus efficace que le film et la
présentation de notre candidature
paris 2012 n'est plus qu'un rêve envolé
c'est londres qui a trouvé la clé des
jeux grâce à la méthode cours londres
qui va donc devenir la première ville à
organiser trois fois les jeux olympiques
d'été immense scène de liesse à
trafalgar square dans le centre de la
ville et dans tout le pays
frédéric protat arnauld miguet explose
littéralement de joie à l'annoncé de la
victoire
les 10000 britanniques réunies sous le
ciel gris londonien partagent le même
bonheur d'avoir su faire la différence
c'est fantastique absolument formidable
ce seront les meilleurs jeux vraiment
les meilleurs et vous les français vous
n'êtes pas trop déçu paris n'était pas
le meilleur le résultat est là et puis
on va pouvoir inviter monsieur chirac a
mérité notre cuisine pour les mérites
ces jeux on est méritée on va organiser
la plus grande fête de la vigne en
direct de glen ball se déroule le g8
bonnie blair remercie tous ceux qui ont
oeuvré pour la victoire
je pense que l'enthousiasmé des
londoniens enthousiasme de toute la
grande bretagne s'est transmis au comité
olympique le rôle joué par le premier
ministre britannique son opération
séduction et relations publiques a été
jugée essentielle de même que la
présentation du dossier par sebastian
coe double médaillé olympique
l'autre atout de londres c'est la
transformation cité olympique d'un des
quartiers les plus défavorisés
stratford à l'est de la capitale
britannique où vivent ensemble sans 35
nationalités
c'est un quartier très particulier de
l'ontt la population est très diverse on
à la diversité ethnique la plus
importante de la planète la population
est très jeune et très active la
jeunesse a été l'un des maîtres mots
développé par la candidature britannique
les jeunes le sport et la passion de
toute une nation recette gagnante
c'était aussi le projet le plus cher on
en reparlera dans un instant d'abord en
direct de londres on retrouve laurent
boussier bonsoir laurent ce soir il ya
de la joie on sent bien mais il ya de la
fierté aussi
vous savez vous avez la devise je crois
que c'est un petit peu la dynamique de
la vistule à la victoire ce soir
évidemment les londoniens sont fiers que
leur villa
les jeux olympiques de 2012 lui son
support surtout fier que londres soit
reconnu un petit peu comme la capitale
de l'europe londres est une ville
dynamique économiquement culturellement
c'est ici que vient de s'installer les
sièges des grandes sociétés
c'est ici que viennent de vivre les
grands artistes c'est ici tu couvres les
restaurants trois étoiles plus que le
dossier sur les jeux 2012 c'est
certainement ce dynamisme ce modèle
social cette ouverture qu'on voulu
récompenser certainement les membres du
cio depuis quelques jours les londoniens
y croyait et il connaissait surtout les
statistiques qui malheureusement montre
que souvent le favori chute dans la
dernière ligne droite
alors ce soir dont londres il y aura
évidemment des fêtes et déjà cet
après-midi les ventes d'alcool se sont
envolés merci lors on revient maintenant
sur le déroulement de cette journée à
suspense
les français emmenés par jacques chirac
et bertrand delanoë étaient les premiers
ce matin à présenter leur dossier
christophe du scion finalement un grand
oral ça n'est rien d'autre qu'un face à
face avec d'un côté les membres du cio
et de l'autre les candidats à
l'organisation des jeux 9 heures passées
à singapour
bertrand delanoë en finit avec une très
courte introduction nous sommes vu mes
clips notre état d'esprit se nourrit
d'humilité et de respect mais aussi
d'exigence et de l' enthousiasme qui
fait battre nos coeurs luc besson a mis
en image fait alchimie unique like annen
vie tu as you parisse thuan des douanes
à ce moment là les jeux sont à paris les
anneaux olympiques triomphe place de
l'étoile
c'est magnifique mais c'est trop beau
pour être vrai c'est du cinéma de luc
besson et rien que du cinéma
c'est bien plus à l'image qu'à l'oral
que le comité d'organisation de paris
2012 a choisi de défendre ses chances
trente cinq minutes de film sur 45
minutes de présentation et une vedette
en capital paris paris paris ce village
il a été conçu par nous les sportifs
pour le sportif derrière paris conjuguer
à tous les temps et cuisine à toutes les
sauces mobilisation générale et
consensuelle des acteurs des sportifs
des chanteurs et même des syndicalistes
jamais en conflit social ne se donnait
pour cible de perturber en soi une
compétition sport derrière paris le
président de la république venu à
singapour avant de repartir au sommet du
g8 la france de pierre de coubertin est
prête à recevoir la flamme olympique
cette flamme qui éclaire l'humanité de
son idéal de paix et de tolérance à la
fin du film bob marley chante en anglais
les anneaux olympiques s'accroche à la
tour eiffel
dans la salle des applaudissements côté
français pourquoi ne pas y croire
merci paris où votre excellente
présentation 14h30 à singapour londres
entre en scène le décor n'a pas changé
mais la stratégie est toute autre
de la princesse anne au maire de londres
ils sont sept à se relayer à la tribune
ils n'étaient que quatre côté français
les anglais ont misé sur la parole pour
tenter de convaincre les examinateurs du
cio
quatre films ont été présentés durée
totale de 12 minutes trois fois moins
long que les français avec une idée
forte un champion olympique c'est un
enfant qui arrive et des jeux
on a beau site web comme sebastian coe
en a rêvé en regardant les jeux de
mexico en 68 à la télé il sera double
champion olympique du 15 100 m et briand
président du comité d'organisation de
londres 2012 message enregistré quelques
mots en français de tony blair aux
membres du cio mais moi j'étais
extrêmement honoré de rencontrer un
grand nombre d'entre vous ces jours
derniers et rapide pouvoir renouer cac
et pillé amitié au delà de la qualité
des dossiers et de la force du lobbying
difficile de mesurer l'impact du grand
oral auprès des membres du cio
mais il est une certitude dans ce
domaine les anglais ne se sont pas
trompés
voilà on retrouve laura flessel
championne olympique plusieurs fois
médaillé en duplex de singapour
alors on vous a vu en larmes et encore
très abattu maintenant encore
apparemment au moment de l'annoncé du
choix ça a été un très un coup très dur
oui un coup de bâton dans le cinsault ou
l'egypte avait fourni un très beau
dossier
il s'était entouré de techniciens les
instances politiques étaient là on a
fait on a
on a demandé l'intervention de luc
besson qui nous a fait une très belle
réalisation
et aujourd'hui on est vraiment déçu
parce que tous ces gens qui ont
contribué à à 7 à cette présentation et
lee ils vont repartir ils seront pas
récompensés
c'est vrai qu'être verte en haut c'était
toute une nation qui était derrière ce
projet mais aujourd'hui est basse et
c'est une grosse désillusion
c'est une déception pour la france pour
vous en tant que sportive ne pas voir se
dérouler les jeux olympiques à paris
c'est aussi une déception j'allais dire
plus plus personnel mais ce n'était pas
uniquement 15 jours de festivités c'est
moi je moi je
c'est vrai que pour 2012 j'avais arrêté
ce que je voyais c'était un pays qui qui
repartaient qui avaient des qui offrait
à son peuple en fait de la création
d'emplois c'est c'était un gros message
d'espoir parce qu'on en avait besoin on
avait besoin de ces jeux pour pour
repartir d'une note plus positive et et
c'est vrai que mes n'y aura plus cette
création d'emplois il y aura passé jeu
et on pourra pas montré notre notre
savoir faire et c'est vrai que
pour des cours des humains ben c'est sûr
que c'est très dur à encaisser
merci à laura flessel elle était avec
nous en début d'après midi en raison du
décalage horaire les athlètes ne sont
pas les seuls déçu à paris il y avait
beaucoup de monde sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville et l'annoncent du
comité olympique en début d'après-midi a
sonné la fin du rêve amaury guibert
vincent kelner la place s'est figé ces
étuis
devant l'hôtel de ville dix mille
personnes stupéfaite pari perdu
certains avaient tout de même anticipé
est qu'aujourd'hui on a trouvé paris
2000 blouses mais franchement voulait
pas de ce crime
voilà c'est désolant et tant mieux pour
londres
tant pis pour paris
les parisiens quand un gros coup de
blues l'amour des jeux s'est envolé la
fanfare prévu pour faire la fête
remballe sur la pointe des pieds un
détour par les champs-elysées une
centaines de parisiens déçus qu'ils
entendent londonien
blanc vo maintenance et support c'est
dommage mais on n'est pas passé loin et
on était sous ce seuil n'est pas le
monde mais en tout cas on a soigné aussi
les y croyez tous pour un nouvel élan
autour du stade de france
c'est raté
aujourd'hui je suis catastrophé c'est
pas grave
sa bonne foi retour à l'hôtel de ville
quelques uns sont restés une dernière
chanson comme un bilan de la candidature
parisienne
on l'a dit près de 90% des français
soutenait cette candidature alors on
attendait la décision un peu partout
images tournées par nos bureaux en
région à la rochelle à lille montpellier
bordeaux et aussi sur la route du tour
de france elles sont rassemblés
commentée par gilles mariner étape du
tour entre chambord et montargis la
nouvelle tombe annoncée par le patron
jean-marie leblanc
13h50 je regarde mon compère marc madiot
qui nous ya lauréate bomba les gars
c'est long cas les jeux grosse déception
pendant que paris boit la tasse laure
manaudou s'entraîne à cannes et dans le
roussillon déçu elle cherche à positiver
c'est pas trop loin de paris non plus
donc avec les supporters et pour ça
pourtant le voyage aussi j'espère et
échevins le bac ex les empêchera pas non
plus de mentionner nager la rochelle ils
étaient plusieurs milliers à espérer que
les anglais à lille sur la grand place
la défaite passe mal très mal
les jeunes n'est en rien tout le monde y
croyait musique funèbre dans ce bar
d'albertville en savoie il faudra se
contenter des souvenirs d'une autre
olympien
après albertville 92 on obligé de croire
à paris 2012
vingt ans après ça a été c'était
merveilleux de retrouver les jeux en
france espoirs envolés
la nouvelle est parvenue jusqu'à sept
plages du sud-ouest à lacanau mais
s'invite à londres
peut-être la chance de les voir quand
même avis
c'est dommage dommage beaucoup d'anglais
dans cette région et certains s'étaient
même persuadé des chances de parry sound
c'est parfait
je pense qu est ce que la france une
dure journée en somme fait de surprises
et d'amertume avec cette consolation les
vacances elles sont bien là
jacques chirac on a entendu tout à
l'heure était venue en personne à
singapour défendre les couleurs
françaises c'est dans l'avion du retour
en volant vers l'ecosse où se tient le
sommet du g8 qu'il a appris la nouvelle
écoutez sa réaction à son arrivée et je
suis naturellement comme toutes les
françaises comme tous les français déçus
par ce jugement du comité mais moi je
tiens à féliciter bien sûr est de tout
coeur
londres les autorités londoniennes et
j'aurai tout al'air l'occasion de
transmettre mes chaleureuses et
personnels félicitations à sa majesté la
reine et au premier ministre tony blair
voilà et nous sommes en duplex de
singapour avec le maire de paris
bertrand delanoë merci d'être avec nous
parce qu'on imagine que c'est une
déception terrible oui nous sommes
terriblement déçu toute l'équipe et je
pense d'abord à tous ceux qui espérait
qu'ils sont à paris en france plus on a
des amis dans le monde entier qui sont
mobilisés donc je veux leur dire que
vraiment j'ai de la peine pour eux et
que tout ce qu'on a semé ensemble
notamment l'équipe de candidature avec
du courage du professionnalisme de
l'exigence et surtout des valeurs de
l'idéal il c'est à dire autour du sport
et des sportifs la manière pour les
peuples de se rencontrer et de vivre de
construire ensemble avec leur différence
donc voilà une défaite un peu
inexplicable puisque moi j'ai rencontré
plein de membres du cio qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils étaient sûrs
qu'on allait gagner bons 54 à 50 pour
londres
c'est curieux mais il faut l'accepter il
faut l'accepter en tentant de sourire je
vous garantis rien mais je veux bien
essayer et vous dit bertrand delanoë
le meilleur a gagné où il y a un peu
d'injustice jeudi
a gagné celui que le cio a choisi et
londres est une ville que j'aime bien et
j'aime bien les anglais simplement on
s'est pas battu de la même manière avec
les mêmes armes donc permettez moi
d'être sport comme je l'étais pendant
plus de deux ans et est de ne pas être
j'ai pas fait la bise à sebastian coe
quoi oui enfin on vous a vu lui serrer
la géniale à 10,1 que les wings donnent
le maire de londres quoi y'a quand même
en a on a entendu un petit début de
polémique quand même où certains ont dit
il ya eu des méthodes britannique qui
n'était pas tout à fait conformes à
l'éthique sportive à l'éthique des jo
vous êtes sur cette position là aussi je
sais pas je ne sais pas on sait pas je
sais que j'ai croisé plein de membres du
cio qui sont pas français 1 et qui me
disent bertrand comprend pas on comprend
pas cette victoire compte tenu de votre
dossier compte tenu de ce que vous avez
fait ce matin dans la présentation
contenu des valeurs que vous avez
défendu ça pouvait pas vous échapper bon
moi je veux pas critiquer tel ou tel jeu
jeudi j'ai fait la bise à ken
livingstone quoique et le maire de
londres sebastian coe l'île nue me voir
j'ai pas fais là disent mais bon c'est
un grand champion je les aime bien mais
je souhaite qu'il réussisse ses jeux
mais bon franchement je vous trouvez
plutôt plus haut point que lui ou que
mais je vais être fort rebond un dernier
mot quand même bertrand delanoë est ce
que vous pensez que le contexte
international où on voit londres se
sentir pousser des ailes tony blair
aussi est-ce que vous pensez que ce
contexte a joué franchement moi
aujourd'hui j'ai été très content qu'on
soit tous rassemblés avec le président
de la république le président de la
région le ministre des sports n'était
tous ensemble et et tant d'autres les
sportifs jean claude killy et guy drut
alain d'année maurice ayrolles henri
sérandour bien sûr et des dizaines de
magnifiques sportive et le contexte sont
avec nous aujourd'hui
donc j'ai pas envie si vous voulez le
trahir cet esprit j'ai remarqué qu'en
manière soir que tony blair il l'a
ramené un peu quoi voilà je le dis
gentiment je veux pas agresser puisque
j'ai dit qu'on va se réfère play pendant
tout le temps avant le vote va pas
manqué de fair play après le vote
j'ai trouvé quand même qu'il la ramenait
beaucoup quoi voilà
et qui avait par exemple hier quand je
monte dans ma chambre à l'hôtel
il y avait des gens qui descendait
d'entretiens avec le premier ministre
britannique moi je paye des entretiens
avec des membres du cio dans ma chambre
puisque de toute façon c'est interdit
par les règles du cio
merci beaucoup en tout cas bertrand
delanoë d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci à tous ceux qui sont tristes en
continu il faut absolument qu'on bâtisse
quelque chose de fort sur ses valeurs et
avec cette énergie ce sera autre chose
merci à bertrand delanoë entretien
enregistré cet après-midi même s'il ya
une volonté de faire play on sent bien
que la défaite a du mal à passer
certains ont franchi le pas il parle
même d'une concurrence déloyale de la
part des britanniques
une controverse est en train de naître
loïc de la mornais londres at elle bien
respecté les règles du jeu dès la
proclamation des résultats les propos de
certains française s'emporte sous le
coup de la déception
une injustice aujourd'hui date de la
part de membres du cio de ne pas avoir
choisi paris c'est un affront pour la
france
d'autres évoquent de manière sibylline
les pratiques douteuses des anglais le
cio les a rappelés à l'ordre
maintes et maintes fois
apparemment les membres ne sont pas
aussi sensibles que et que certaines
enfin que certaines choses qui se
passent au cio excusez-moi de près de
claire mais pas rentrer dans les détails
il ya eu des manières de fonctionner qui
était un peu spéciale maintenant si
aujourd'hui dans l'autre monde c'est
payant bas la preuve aujourd'hui
peut-être y at-il une explication toute
simple les anglais sont meilleurs que
nous en lobbying pour gagner un contrat
en affaires il faut séduire être
agressif relancer les gens autant de
choses que les britanniques ont su faire
tony blair en tête depuis les visites du
cio à londres jusqu'à la dernière minute
à singapour quant à la france elle a
peut-être surestimé sa réputation
internationale et son rayonnement
le comité s'est passé ces anglo saxons
c'est les anglais 1
franchement je comprend pas les membres
du cio ont peut être préféré londres
l'activé cosmopolite face à la france
parfois jugée un peu trop sûre d'elle
la presse a prêté à jacques chirac il ya
quelques jours des propos ironiques sur
la mauvaise qualité de la cuisine
anglaise et finlandaises réponse
cinglante aujourd'hui d'un commissaire
européen finlandais
il déclare qu après les propos peu
amènes du président français il est
heureux de féliciter la victoire de
londres ajoutant en français dans le
texte
j'aime la france
une phrase que les français pourraient
ressasser durant quelques années encore
bonsoir florent gautreau vous êtes en
direct de singapour alors c'est vrai que
d'un point de vue technique les deux
dossiers étaient équivalents mais
londres avait aussi d'autres atouts
trois échecs en 20 ans david ça ne peut
pas être de la malchance il y a des
explications alors la désillusion
d'aujourd'hui elle marque le manque de
représentativité d'abord des français
dans les instances internationales du
sport à la fédération d'athlétisme de
judo de handball ou à l inverse les
anglo saxons se tailler la part du lion
ensuite c'est l'échec d'une méthode une
méthode certes transparente on l'a vu
avec bertrand delanoë
mais inefficace il faut se rendre à
l'évidence puisque c'est le le troisième
échec et le lobbying on l'a vu le biniou
londonien et l'activisme de tony blair
font merveille et puis l'analyse du vote
est intéressante parce qu'eux-mêmes
madrid grâce au réseau toujours actifs
de l'ancien président du cio juan
antonio samaranch mm madrid a failli
bouter paris lors de la finale à deux
voix près ça s'est joué au troisième
tour nous revient alors en mémoire ce
que disait le prince albert de monaco
tout à l'heure il nous disait il ya
certains membres du cio qui ne disent
même pas de rapport d'évaluation et puis
on sait aussi que c'est éminemment
politique c'est la troisième raison ce
vote du cio toujours il y a quatre ans
il fallait donner les jeux à pékin et à
son influence grandissante sur la
planète est aujourd'hui en europe ce
n'est plus la france qui est le fer de
lance et ironie de l'histoire c'est
plutôt l'angleterre et une élection ou
ici au seuil haut ça ne se gagne pas
seulement sur le terrain mais beaucoup
dans la coulisse olympique
florent un mot quand même ce projet de
londres avec 15 milliards d'euros
c'était quand même de très loin le plus
cher de tous oui d'autant que londres un
stade olympique encore à construire
mais là aussi il faut reconnaître que la
commission d'évaluation avait été très
clair je la cite l avais dit que le
budget de londres et détails et bien
étayé et réalisables donc rien dire rien
à dire a priori il a encore on en
revient à la politique la bonne santé
économique de l'angleterre dû convaincre
les membres du cio à l'heure du vote
merci florent et pianoteq le premier
ministre français dominique de villepin
exprimant lui aussi sa déception indiqué
que les équipements prévus à paris et
ailleurs vélodrome base nautique aux
piscines olympiques seront bien
construit en tout cas il y avait entre
paris et londres
un match dans le match celui des hommes
jacques chirac et tony blair tony blair
à qui tout réussit en ce moment arnaud
boutet
entre les deux ce fut longtemps une
grande amitié
aujourd'hui cela ressemble à une
bataille musclée
dernier épisode de ce bras de fer
singapour tony blair et jacques chirac
ont effectué le même voyage en s'évitant
soigneusement à chacun sa méthode
face au fighting spirit lan vie de
convaincre la france oppose le respect
des règles dans le monde olympique ça
veut dire plaît mais lorsqu'il évoque le
rosbif le fair play des pas toujours de
règles à kaliningrad face à gerhard
schröder et vladimir poutine
jacques chirac aurait déclaré à propos
des anglais la seule chose qu'ils ont
faite dont l'agriculture européenne
c'est la vache folle on ne peut pas
faire confiance à des gens qui ont une
cuisine aussi mauvaise
ces propos démentis par l'elysée mais le
malaise reste profond car il concerne
plusieurs gros dossiers
la politique agricole commune tony blair
veut la réforme et le rabais britannique
jacques chirac souhaite le modifier lors
du dernier conseil européen
jacques chirac n'a pu que constater
l'intransigeance du premier ministre
britannique a voulu garder l'intégralité
de son chèque
et pourtant trois jours auparavant il
avait tenté de se mettre d'accord
si la rencontre que je viens d'avoir
avec le président chirac a été amicale
mais de toute évidence chat julien des
accords aiguë et je pense qu'il est
difficile de combler ses différents
deux générations deux visions du monde
mais jacques chirac traverse une série
noire alors que tony blair est un homme
à qui tout réussit une image pour
refermer ce chapitre images des autres
déçus du jour en particulier à madrid où
on y croyait aussi les espagnols
s'étaient rassemblés sur la place à
mayol au coeur de la capitale devant un
écran géant et sous une chaleur déjà
écrasante la ville éliminée au 3e tour
n'avait que deux voix de retard sur
paris à moscou aussi des milliers de
personnes s'étaient regroupées sur la
place rouge la capitale russe a été
sorti au premier tour juste avant new
york on évoqué jacques chirac et tony
blair et bien il se retrouve en ce
moment en écosse pour l'ouverture du g8
la réunion des huit pays les plus
industrialisés du monde commence ce soir
par un dîner dans la ville de
gleaneagles dehors les manifestants sont
toujours là yann fronty dominique
marault tél des hélicoptères militaires
ont été appelés en renfort à bord des
dizaines de policiers anti-émeutes à
quelques mètres la grille d'enceinte n'a
pas résisté
les services de sécurité avait pourtant
vu les choses en grand en érigeant une
clôture de 8 km de long pour protéger le
château de gleneagles
mais cela n'a pas suffi en fin
d'après-midi les manifestants ont réussi
à rentrer dans la zone rouge malgré un
dispositif impressionnant ils ont vite
été contenu
un peu plus tôt ils étaient plusieurs
milliers à s'être rassemblés dans le
village voisin pour défiler contre la
politique menée par les membres du g8
c'est trop injuste que ce soit seulement
huit chefs d'état qui décide pour le
reste du monde et pour les pays en voie
de développement est pour nous important
que la société civile mondiale se
mobilisent puisque ceux qui sont censés
diriger le monde font des promesses qui
ne sont pas tenues
tôt ce matin les premières ont éclaté
ils ont opposé des centaines de
manifestants très mobiles agissant par
petits groupes à des forces de l'ordre
souvent débordé au nord d'edimbourg
l'autoroute a été bloquée quelques
heures au final près de 60 personnes ont
été arrêtées
des troubles qui n'ont pas perturbé un
protocole est un programme parfaitement
minutes et ce matin tony blair est
arrivé en hélicoptère le premier suivi
par george bush dans l'après midi
ce soir tous les grands de ce monde
seront réunis pour le premier jour de ce
g8 la reine d'angleterre en est l'hôte
d'honneur
au menu les sujets qui seront abordés
dès demain comme la dette des pays
pauvres ou encore le réchauffement
climatique
autre moment très attendu la poignée de
main entre jacques chirac et tony blair
à monaco c'est maintenant officiel le
prince albert a reconnu publiquement
être le père d'un garçon de 22 mois issu
d'une liaison avec une ancienne hôtesse
de l'air
autre confirmation s'est précisée dans
le communiqué l'enfant ne pourra pas
prétendre à la succession
mais il aura bien sa part d'héritage
thierry curtet olivier robert le
communiqué fait deux pages il est signé
d'un avocat mais ce sont les propos du
prince albert
extraits il a reconnu sept enfants et
souhaitent ils puissent vivre en étant
strictement tenu à l'écart des médias
c'est pourtant paris match qui révèle au
grand public l'existence d' alexandre 20
mois le bébé a pour maman une hôtesse de
l'air nicole coste d'origine togolaise
pour l'état civil jusqu'à aujourd'hui
son père et est inconnue mais le
communiqué changea certain nombre de
choses tout d'abord l'enfant un père
officiel et le prince plus à trouver un
toit
cette discrète maison non loin de monaco
pour abriter alexandre et sa mère en
fait le prince albert a attendu la fin
du deuil de trois mois pour reconnaître
son fils
mais le prince de monaco a tenu dans le
même communiqué a précisé un point
important cette affaire relève
uniquement de la sphère réserve et de
l'intimité de la vie privée sans
incidence aucune sur l'avenir de la
dynastie
en d'autres mots le jeune alexandre
pourra hériter des biens que lui les
gras son père mais ne pourra prétendre
au trône monégasque en l'état actuel de
la vente et du prince la situation dans
le var au lendemain de l' incendie très
virulent à puget-sur-argens tout est
rentré dans l'ordre les vacanciers ont
retrouvé leurs tentes et leurs mobiles
homes le feu a tout de même détruit une
dizaine de maisons et de caravanes l'
enquête des gendarmes a commencé dès ce
matin paul de genève olivier théron sur
place le feu est passé et a laissé
derrière lui 800 hectares de désolation
l'incendié est éteint quelques
fumerolles rappelle toutefois qu'il n'a
peut être pas rendu son dernier souffle
le dispositif a été allégé 200 pompiers
sont toujours mobilisés dans le massif
des maures dans les campings évacué hier
après-midi les vacances ont repris au
rythme des 6 jan
ici un seul mobile homes a brûlé sans
propriétaire anglais dit qu'il n'a pas
eu de chance d'ailleurs comme lui aucun
touriste ne songe à partie dans
l'ensemble tout va bien pas de problème
un problème je crois que tout le monde a
su que bon le camp était sauvé tout va
bien pour nous il ya plus de rejet la
bombe ont dû sécuriser quand même parce
que bon on va que les pompiers sont sur
le site et puis qui surveille les lieux
toute la journée les pompiers ou noyer
les lisières pour contrer les reprises
en espérant que le vent ne soit pas trop
violent lorsque c'est quasiment éteint
il faut faire très attention aux
reprises
et lorsque le vent d'ouest arrive on a
le taux d'humidité dans l'air qui
diminue les températures qui augmente et
on a des risques de reprise donc c'est
ça notre risque aujourd'hui les ponts
qui reste extrêmement vigilant
en fin d'après-midi un nouveau départ de
feu sur la route de bagnols en forêt a
été très rapidement maîtrisé
il est trop tôt pour dire si ces
incendies sont accidentelles ou
criminelles pourtant éléments troublants
l'un des deux départs de feu recensés
hier se situe exactement sous une ligne
à très haute tension ce qui rend
impossible l'intervention des moyens
aériens
lors des premières minutes de l'incendié
justice le débat sur la récidive et les
récidivistes on en parlait récemment
après laffaire crémel et les mises en
cause de nicolas sarkozy est bien le
gouvernement confirme que la loi sera
durci le nouveau garde des sceaux pascal
clément a proposé une série de mesures
point phare l'allongement de la peine
incompressible pour les condamnés à
perpétuité
dominique verdeilhan bernard connor
chaque fait divers tragique en jambes
des modifications législatives un mois
après l'assassinât de nelly crémel par
un condamné à perpétuité en libération
conditionnelle
le garde des sceaux a défendu ce matin
cet amendement devant la commission des
lois dont il était encore récemment le
président pour un condamné à perpétuité
la période où il ne pourrait pas sortir
de prison passerait de 15 à 18 ans pour
un récidiviste la durée passerait de 18
à 22 ans
autre volonté gouvernementale lors de
l'audience statuant sur une libération
conditionnelle
les victimes pourraient faire entendre
leur position par la voix de leur avocat
en juillet 2004 les affaire fourniret
bodin avait déjà interpellé magistrats
et politique
un an plus tard la commission ben hur
jaulin rend sa copie pour les pénalement
irresponsables ceux pour qui la justice
ne peut rien faire
le procureur avis
préfet en vue d'un éventuel placement
psychiatrique
enfin création d'un centre fermé de
protection sociale ce n'est plus une
prison ce n'est pas tout à fait un
hôpital pour les condamnés en fin de
peine
l'idée c'est qu'un homme qui a fini sa
peine mais qui est considérée par les
psychiatres extrêmement dangereux pour
la société ne puisse plus me lâcher
lâché t ça les français nous le
demandent
ces établissements existe déjà en
allemagne aux pays bas au canada en
france selon le ministère cela pourrait
concerner plus de 700 personnes
une information sur notre maison notre
groupe france télévisions qui regroupe
france 2 france 3 france 4 france 5 et
france ô
eh bien il a un nouveau président il a
été désigné aujourd'hui par le csa il
s'agit de patrick de carolis
un visage qui vous ai connu puisqu'il
présente sur france 3 le magazine des
racines et des ailes
il succède à marc tessier valérie
fournis ou edward bourgeons à la sortie
de son grand oral face aux membres du
csa s'est immédiatement l'homme de
télévision qui réagit et ce plus
difficile et plus impressionnant détendu
semble-t-il tout s'est bien passé
soulagé et il a su les convaincre élus
ce matin dès le premier tour par cinq
voix sur neuf
patrick de carolis 51 ans devient le
nouveau pdg du groupe france télévisions
un journaliste un professionnel de
l'image patrick de carolis a commencé sa
carrière en 1974 à fr3 après tf1 antenne
de l a5
il a créé et présenté en 93 l'émission
zone interdite sur m6 où il devient
directeur de l'information
il est également l'auteur de plusieurs
livres dont un entretien avec bernadette
chirac en 97 il renoue avec le service
public et lance sur france 3 cette
émission culturelle est accessible au
plus grand nombre des valeurs attachées
aux services publics les appliquer à
l'échelle du groupe c le but qu'il s'est
fixé
patrick de carolis à cinq ans pour mener
à bien cette réforme qu'il a qualifié
lui même de projets ambitieux fait un
1er janvier janvier en portent l'entière
de france le sprinteur tom boonen a bien
failli remporter sa troisième victoire
d'affilée dans une étape en ligne il
devancé sur le fil par l'australien
robbie mcewen pas de changement au
classement général mais lance armstrong
a pris le départ ce matin sans son
maillot jaune julien benedetto emmanuel
bec surprise ce matin chambord lance
armstrong se présente au départ sans son
maillot jaune est une manière de rendre
hommage à son compatriote david
zabriskie privé de sa tunique de leader
hier après une chute sous la pression de
la direction
le sextuple vainqueur du tour enfilera
finalement son maillot jaune
ce maillot jaune le hongrois laszlo
bodrogi de l'équipe crédit agricole la u
10 actuellement sur les épaules
échappé avec trois autres courageux
pendant plus de cent kilomètres avant de
voir le peloton fondre sur lui à grande
vitesse il y avait des moments tendus en
plus il pleuvait donc très très nerveux
et c'est vrai que c'est des journées de
grande tension et nerveusement c'est
difficile à vivre et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont nerveux ces derniers kilomètres
piégé par un virage en épingle
l'estonien to back ne verra pas le duel
de costauds sur la ligne d'arrivée à
montargis le belge boon haine envers ce
fait souffler la victoire par
l'australien mcewen
décidément les sprinteurs ont la vie
belle ans débute lui est directement lié
aux physionomies ce soir l'ensemble tout
ne s'est pas fait prier pour endosser
son deuxième maillot jaune du tour
le jaune n'est pour l'instant pas une
priorité pour lui de quoi donner des
idées aux attaquants dans les prochains
jours elle l'avait enlevée au départ par
solidarité avec david zabriskie le
précédent maillot jaune qui avait chuté
la veille c'est une tradition dans le
tour de france
et puis de l'athlétisme avec une bonne
nouvelle aujourd'hui pour les couleurs
tricolores pour la première fois un
français descendu sous la barre des 10
secondes et 100 m 9 secondes 9 9
secondes 99 centièmes pour ronald pognon
23 ans le martiniquais a remporté la
course hier au grand prix de lausanne
il a devancé quelques-uns des plus
grands sprinteurs du moment les
rencontres de la photographie d'arles
parmi les expositions proposées cette
année la collection d'un particulier un
américain il est passionné de photo
depuis des années il accumule les
clichés qui ont tous un point commun ce
sont des portraits mais aucun modèle ni
dévoile son regard
isabelle bessler olivier robert bilal
ancien comédien new-yorkais a consacré
ces trente dernières années à la
photographie c'est un collectionneur
obsessionnel lui qui prétendait ne pas
avoir d'oeil au départ le chercher en
fait que des portraits dans le regard
était absent ou pour le moins perturbé
son mot d'ordre no eyes la plupart des
portraits sont nuls
elles portent rien at the c'est de
l'information premier degré dès qu'on
cache qu'on retire une partie de la
formation ue le spectateur fait
travailler son imagination il obligé
d'aller à la rencontre de l'artiste lost
gagné par la passion de la photographie
bilan a fait son métier
il a à titre privé acquis près d'un
millier de tirage à l'étrange points
comme un regard absent mieux masquer à
chaque édition des rencontres d'arles
expose une grande collection
international bel 20 a fait le
déplacement
derniers réglages de l'accrochage le
choix si singulier de bil'in est au
centre du festival cette année plus de
320 de ses mille photos ont traversé
l'atlantique pour l'été tous les grands
noms de l'histoire de la photo ils sont
tous à 1120 quelques fois que des photos
qu'on n'attend pas d'eux et puis surtout
c'est une créativité une poésie
absolument bouleversante un exercice
aussi qui peut paraître bien impudique
temps chaque photo parle de l'intimité
du collectionneur ici il se voit en
jeune homme là il se projette dans son
couple ses tripes s'expose quand il
choisit des images de la beauté et que
toujours les yeux fermés ou absents
elles voisinent avec celle de la mort ou
de la douleur les angoisses les
fantasmes les rêves l'inconscient du
collectionneur s'expose recréer le
discours de sa vie et cherche un écho
dans la nôtre fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo isabelle martinet 21h fbi portés
disparus 00h30 dernier journal laurence
piquet dès 6h30 et les matins dans la
case vérité gérard leclerc recevra soeur
john fowles ambassadeur de grande
bretagne en france on se quitte sur ce
nouveau nouvel exemple de ce qu'on
appelle le belge est toujours plus loin
toujours plus intrépides
cette fois les soirs en parachute se
déroule à partir du téléphérique des
diablerets en suisse sept secondes de
chute libre en plein de l'acier avant
d'ouvrir la voile ça n'est pas donné à
tout le monde
à demain
non